Norman : Pourquoi ça marche pas ça ?
Jamy : C'est peut-être la résistance qui est morte.
Elle entoure la mèche qui est imbibée de propylène glycol et s'il n'y a pas de montée en température bah,
il y a pas de vapeur.
Norman : Je connais cette voix !?
Jamy : Ou alors, c'est la cheminée qui est bouchée !
Norman : *pfou*
Ah ouais c'est bon!
Jamy : Euh non, justement, c'est pas très bon, il y'a plus de goudron,
mais il y a toujours de la nicotine.
Norman : Mais t'es Jamy !?
Jamy : Euh oui,  je crois.
Norman : Je peux t'offrir un petit verre ?
Jamy : Avec plaisir!
Norman : Let's go!
Alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas, Jamy ou plutôt Jamy Guy Bernard Gourmaud,
c'est le présentateur de plein
d'émissions scientifiques et culturelles à la télé depuis les années 90 à aujourd'hui.
Notamment une émission cultissime qui a bercé tous les gens de ma génération et plus: "C'est pas sorcier".
Jamy : Le serré c'est pour toi
*bruitage*
Norman : Dans la vie dès que tu touches un objet ça fait ce bruit là ou..?
Jamy : Bah oui.
*bruitage*
Norman : Alors Jamy,  je sais pas si tu le sais mais tu corresponds à 95% de toute ma culture scientifique.
Grâce entre autres à l'émission "C'est pas sorcier".
Alors je sais que tu n'as pas forcément envie que l'on t'associe uniquement à cette émission
mais est-ce que tu peux répondre à trois questions où toute ma génération, on s'est toujours posées
Jamy : Bouge pas, faut que je réfléchisse.
Jamy : Allez vas-y!
Norman : Vous êtes toujours amis avec Fred?
Jamy : Ouais on est toujours potes, évidemment. On s'appelle régulièrement, on déjeune régulièrement ensemble. On est toujours potes avec Fred, avec Sabine
la petite voix, toute l’équipe de "C'est pas sorcier"
Norman : Après toutes ces années, est-ce que l'on peut enfin savoir à quoi ressemble Marcel?
Jamy : En fait, c'est vrai que tout le monde se pose des questions sur l'existence de Marcel. Eh bien oui, Marcel existe.
Aaah!
Jamy : Voilà regarde cette photo.
Norman : Ah ouais!
Jamy : C'est quand même un sacré bonhomme.
Voix : Vous vous êtes bien fait avoir.
Norman : Pourquoi "C'est pas sorcier" ça s'est terminé?
Jamy : Euh! "C'est pas sorcier" à duré 19 ans. 19 ans c'est long. Il y avait problablement un petit peu d'érosion d'audience.
Et puis, "C'est pas sorcier" a donné plein d'idées à des jeunes auteurs plein de talent qui ont pris le relais sur le web.
Norman : Dans ta carrière, tu as fait pleins de choses assez diversifiées. Tu as fait l'émission du "Monde de Jamy", "Quelle aventure!"
Tu te considères toi-même comme une sorte de passeur de savoir
Est-ce que tu étais prédestiné à ça?
Jamy : Alors pas un milieu scientifique, en revanche, très tôt, j'ai eu envie moi d'être journaliste, pas scientifique, Hein, Attention! Journaliste!
Je crois qu'à 12 ans, j'avais déjà envie de faire ce métier.
J'ai commencé, euh... à faire ce métier, euh... en radio et en presse écrite.
Et ce que j'aimais faire, c'était décortiquer les mécanismes mais pas forcément des mécanismes scientifiques. Quand je me suis retrouvé un peu par hasard
à bosser sur des sujets scientifiques
Ca me convenait bien.
Norman : Pour toi quelle est la plus grande découverte scientifique de ces dernières années?
Jamy : J'ai été très impressionné par le dernier engin que l'on a réussi à poser sur Mars
"Insight". On a réussi à le poser sur Mars et il est commandé depuis la Terre, on est en train de préparer
notre futur voyage, quand je dis notre, celui des Hommes, sur la planète Mars.
Il y a aussi tout le travail que l'on est en train de faire aujourd'hui sur les arbres, sur la manière dont communiquent les arbres, notamment.
Norman : Les les armes ou les arbres?
Jamy : Les arbres.
Norman : Pardon.
Selon toi, à quoi ressemblera l'équipage lorsque l'on posera le premier pied sur Mars?
Jamy : C'est un sacré pari. C'est quand même un voyage qui va durer 6 mois dans un sens, 6 mois dans l'autre.
Alors je pense que ça sera un équipage international, un petit peu, ce qu'il se passe dans la Station spatiale internationale
Où on a en permanence des européens, des américains, des russes.
Norman : Si je te donne ça...
Jamy : Oui, c'est un caillou.
Norman : En plus... Ouais c'est ça! Allez, bonne soirée!
Jamy : je veux bien t'aider voila effectivement c'est un caillou sale
Norman : Alors, j'ai appris que tu avais un astéroïde à ton nom
Jamy : C'est vrai
Norman : Voilà c’était le p'tit lien que je j'ai voulu créer avec ce caillou... Est-ce que tu peux nous en dire plus ?
Jamy : En fait, c'est un, un astronome qui a découvert ces trois astéroïdes et quand on découvre
un astéroïde et bien on
on en informe l'Union astronomique internationale et on propose de les baptiser
Et donc, cet astronome qui aimait bien "C'est pas sorcier" a proposé à l'Union internationale astronomique de les baptiser du nom de Fred, Sabine et Jamy.
Norman : t'es un grand connaisseur de science, d'histoire et plus encore; tu connais plein de choses c'est assez impressionnant, est-ce que il y a un domaine dans lequel t'es pas du tout calé ?
Jamy : En fait, il y a plein de domaines dans lesquels je ne suis pas calé et je suis même très content, très content d'être très loin de tout savoir parce que moi mon plaisir
c'est pas de savoir, c'est d'apprendre.
Norman : Encore une question.
Jamy : Euh Norman ? T'en as encore beaucoup comme ça ? Tu veux pas qu'on aille faire un tour ?
Norman : D'accord donc je te saoule.. euh mmhh ouais.
Jamy : Je n'ai pas dit ça!
Jamy : Nous sommes au Musée National d'Histoire Naturelle, dans la galerie de paléontologie au milieu des squelettes de dinosaures
Norman : Dis donc Jamy, savais-tu que les avalanches peuvent parfois faire 250 m de haut
Jamy : Norman, les références à "C'est pas sorcier", ça va hein
On me fait ça tous les jours!
*Musique épique*
Jamy : C'est un endroit où j'adore venir parce que on est dans un endroit de transmission du savoir
Quand je parle de transmission du savoir c'est
surtout la compréhension qui m'intéresse. Il y en a un qui est suspendu là, c'est un ptérodactyle. C'est pas un oiseau hein, c'est un dinosaure volant.
Norman : Ah ouais, moi je connais le ptérodactyle par rapport à Power Rangers
Norman : Ouai j'ai des références plutôt culturelles, plutôt pointues hein ?
Jamy : Ouai c'est bien, je n'y avais pas pensé !
Norman : T'imagines la taille du sac à main qu'on peut faire avec ça ?!
Le Mammouth ! ... Qui a donné son nom au supermarché, et également au pétard.
Très massif hein ce mammouth
Jamy : Balaise, ouai
Norman : Très bien membré!
Jamy : Ça on ne sait pas!
Norman : Et donc, pour remettre la base, les dinosaures ont disparu de la planète Terre à cause de l'ère glacière, c'est ça ?
Jamy : Non.
Norman : Yes. Merci à tous!
Jamy : La disparition des dinosaures, elle est due à vraisemblablement deux phénomènes concomitants. Il y a une météorite,
une énorme météorite qui est tombée sur la Terre, et cette explosion a projeté dans l'atmosphère une poussière phénoménale qui a entouré
la planète pendant plusieurs années.
Jamy : Plus de végétation, ils ont plus rien à bouffer; et de fil en aiguille ils ont disparu.
Norman : Donc là c'est la partie qui est dédiée à tout ce qui est baleine.
Jamy : Tu sais pourquoi on appelle les tiges d'un parapluie des baleines ?
Norman : Ah non!
Jamy : Parce qu'à l'origine c'était fabriqué avec les fanons des baleines.
Norman : Ohhhh ça c'est intéréssant ça dis donc !
Jamy : En fait des fanons c'est des espèces de tiges, de structures un peu osseuses,
qui permettent aux baleines de filtrer la nourriture. Pendant des siècles on a pensé que c'était un poisson,
c'est l'un des responsables du Museum national d'Histoire naturelle qui a, le premier, découvert, mis en avant que la baleine était un mammifère,
comme toi et moi, et non pas un poisson. Ca c'est un bras avec l'épaule,
l'humérus, le radius, le cubitus. Et là ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Norman: Eh bah c'est la main !
Jamy : Exactement ! Regarde, si je me mets dans le même sens que la baleine,
clac,
on a exactement la même main !
Norman: C'est très ressemblant !
Jamy: C'est génial, non?!
Jamy: Alors si on résume notre histoire à une journée de 24h: la Terre s'est formée à 00h, les dinosaures apparaissent à 23h20, et l'Homme à 23h59, et 45 secondes.
Norman: Ouai! Et pourquoi moi je suis habillé en dinosaure en fait ?!
Jamy: Ca c'est juste pour que tu te tapes la honte.
Norman: Ah ouai t'es sérieux là??!
Norman: Merci Jamy, j'ai vraiment passé une journée très cool avec toi! J'ai appris des trucs, je me suis bien marré,
donc voilà, c'est juste un au revoir et un à bientôt ?
Jamy: Ah bah écoute moi j'étais... Ah!
Norman: Bon, on la refait sans la crampe, merci pour tout !
Jamy: Merci Norman ! J'ai passé une très bonne journée avec toi, ça fait du bien de sourire :)
Norman: Bon, j'imagine que tu rentres en fusée ?
Jamy? Jamy??
Ooh!!
Jamy: Salut Norman! Et merci pour la vidéo!
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo avec Jamy, c'était archi cool
Je suis désormais encore plus fan de lui
Alors petite question, qui aimeriez-vous voir dans une prochaine vidéo de rencontre?
Répondez dans les commentaires. À bientôt !
Petite voix : T'as pas l'impression d'oublier quelqu'un là Norman?
Norman: Qui me parle là ?
Petite voix off: Bah c'est moi la petite voix ! A chaque fois c'est moi qu'on oublie, c'est toujours pareil j'en ai marre :(
Norman: Ah mais oui la petite voix de "C'est pas sorcier" !
Petite voix off: De toutes façons y'en a toujours que pour Jamy et Fred, ça commence à bien faire
Norman: Pas du tout c'est juste que, j'ai pas pensé ! Je suis aussi hyper fan de vous hein ! C'est pas ça le problème mais...
Petite voix off: Ouai c'est ça bien sur. Allez, chauffe Merlin, chauffe !
Norman: Ok ! Ok ! D'accord ! Allez, à bientôt !
Petite voix off: Ah beh c'est dur de se faire entendre ici !
Hey ! Si vous avez apprécié la vidéo, mettez un petit pouce en l'air !
Et puis si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à la chaîne du ch'ti Norman, c'est le moment de le faire !
Vous appuyez sur sa petite tête là. Voilà, allez, ciao tout le monde !
SOUS-TITRE PAR YouTuber 28